[Music]
so this coronavirus huh
pretty crazy fake-ass virus why'd you
think where are people dying no they
rely so those my let there's been a
whistleblower they accidentally gave out
the real numbers and the real numbers is
not 300 confirmed its twenty four
thousand with over seventy four thousand
infected wait so how's that fake better
support from the Chinese government no
it was like a UH like a data thing they
had one set of numbers for the Chinese
government and another set of numbers or
the public look at the public yeah
24,000 of died yeah estimated whistle
blow oh I also got sent an interview
from some guy saying that some research
whatever has shown that it's not
actually from one like just something
that was no no I heard a spear see that
you're talking about yeah it's not from
the bat it's not from the bats that it
was creating a lab that's next to Wuhan
yeah leaked out somehow god I don't like
biological warfare weapons that I nearly
got leaped out or something yeah and
that the and that they spun it so that
it's like go people eat that soup and
[ __ ] don't you already think that some
some of these Chinese people are trash
right that's that's part they made
racist among their own people
no that's what the specie says there's a
lot of theories out there the spear see
takes people's ignorance it's like old
Chinese people are trash and and goes
like yeah they were eating that soup
right and so they look shitty and then
they that's how it dispersed that's
that's what people were I don't think I
was trash adventure that's why do you
think aids came from somebody [ __ ] a
monkey's [ __ ] the monkey and its you
know it's interesting it's like oh yeah
that's right it's interesting to think
that you know this disease popped up
where like you know in one of the most
populated countries like is it like a
fan OHS type situation where it's like
pop control population can because of
right now the latest number I have is at
least five hundred and sixty-five people
have died and twenty more than
28-thousand have been infected that's
almost the part that I'm that scares me
the least though is that the death rate
is very low
considering right so that's a 10% death
rate which is very good as far as like
survivability the human race if this was
to go everywhere but if it was 24,000
that's a different story but still 10%
of the human population is a [ __ ]
crazy number right so why does that
concern you you see that concerns you no
no I said that that gives me a little
bit of a concern I feel like every so
often there's always something that
happens in Asia and then there's like
this huge scare that goes on like SARS
so I flew every couple of years it's
like oh here's the new thing to be
afraid of yeah why is China always do
it's almost like it gets Club bunch of
clicks but I will say that the this one
is bigger than those by far so oh yeah
this is the biggest one that it's
reached here to my discipline to confirm
places yeah state is quarantine in their
own people I think 30 million people in
quarantine that says a lot
oh you know there was like there was
like literally two people in Italy you
heard my Italy like that do people
bother me like like Chinese tourists and
Italy was like that's it
state of emergency we're shutting it
down no one's allowed from China that's
it and they're like yo yeah for real I
appreciate that way to people with
coronavirus came to Italy yeah yes
Chinese Corona
yeah like confirmed they have two people
come from China did Chinese people with
corona or not just not just to Chinese
people walking around I thought that too
like when they heard of the outbreak
they're the first two that came into
their like from China did you read the
paper to Chinese people went to Italy
how many million did you say it's it's a
30-30 what do you what are the people in
quarantine throw yeah thirty million
people that's were here so there that
was last week a hundred and thirteen
million resident Lord yeah that are try
that are required to wear masks on the
daily to help contain the virus and so
there are Chinese authorities that have
now taken it upon themselves to
fly drones in their cities and in the
countryside and yell at people who don't
have face masks war so I'm gonna show
you guys a video clip that have gone
viral baby ran out of face masks though
what if they don't have one I don't know
have you seen the meme with the lady in
the bus that has a mask
ah but instead of it on her mouth it's
on her yeah what it's like when you hate
people more than I saw one where they
had a big huge bottle like this and he
just put it on their head they cut a
bottom and then they put the whole
volume on sighs it's the size of your
head it's a big job okay I thought
they'd strap the bottom of their head oh
thank god I can't get corroded it's like
I heard like an old thing where if you
get on your feet yeah it was like you
know out in the snow that's crazy how
does he know like how do they know that
they don't have the masks on these are
they watching video there's no the drone
is
the drone knows that if there's a mask
or not there's a human yeah it's not
like a recorder the dude with a peep
code on your motorbike yeah you please
put on your mask
handsome guys I saw you both but Master
P's wear your mask
I like the music hey pretty young
Heidi's eating and walking
put on your mask hurry up does anybody
put the mask on it doesn't look like it
no one obeys Allah there huh there's one
lady who refused to put her mask on and
this situation escalated his shot darts
at her at the drone she was shopping and
she refused to wear the mask and that's
when they there were a whole bunch of
officers that ended up pinning her down
on the ground [ __ ] at some supermarket
and they arrested her we're not on her
math isn't it just one less person
that's gonna be around then if she
catches it it's like whoa no because
then it spreads to other people yeah so
they're trying to prevent the spread
does video pictures know it's a photo I
know she have a Burberry [ __ ] scarf
around her eyes so she was taken to the
hospital and she was tested negative for
the virus but did y'all see that
hospital they built in like five weeks
seven days ten days or some [ __ ] like
yeah I was like a really huge Hospital
and then there's like a time-lapse like
fully functioning and [ __ ] that's scary
that's 3d printed that [ __ ] yeah it was
made to like help like I don't know like
500 yeah that's amazing
it's created it the second of two
hospitals built in record time Andrew on
to isolate and treat patients which has
killed more than 560 people the 1600 bed
hospital
I was ready to accept patients three
days after the opening I'm scary I've
got been when your master the airport
like I heard the lung people I don't
even really do they don't has to be like
n95 like and co eyes the whole thing is
like it when you take it off you exposed
yourself right because the Masters right
there oh you're supposed to specific way
alter either so there's that and then
the regular mask there's just no filter
for the virus I was at the airport and I
had a man who's there expensive and I'm
like ice I had Milo like my little cool
mask on and then I started like like a
lot of people wearing masks most more
Asian or something like like all these
people are all he's not Asian people are
just looking at us like he's another
[ __ ] Asians get their mass yeah yeah
let me take mine off but then but you
know here's like a [ __ ] cool travel
hack sleeping with the mask on plane is
lit did you do that yeah you don't have
to worry about like your mouth being
wide open
reason why I wear mass is because I like
it a lot my nose gets cold like this
bone here it's weird so I like covering
it cool you know it's weird and then I
realized I don't know where I got this
idea from but I remember being younger
and seeing people wearing masks and
thinking they're ninjas but I used to
think this this thought which was what
the [ __ ] they think they're so cool
they're wearing [ __ ] mask like who
the [ __ ] why would I think that but now
that I know the masks are kind of cool
like that I don't know but it just came
off as like there it was like a try-hard
thing to me had the child I thought it
was a try-hard thing Gillis is that
where were you why would people wearing
masks I don't know but no but it was
like Asian people were mad that would
never really you know I grew up in
Mexican neighborhoods I never really
would see Asian so then when I see them
with mass I'm like [ __ ] but I didn't I
didn't pin it to only Asians wear a mask
anyway she's an awesome Chinese
[ __ ] they're so cool no later on
now that I know the reason why people
were mass is because they're sick they
want to protect others and now I think
like damn what a dick what about when
you saw the painters and they had the
masks are no how did these painters new
song cool no dude they're working all
I'm talking about people I used to think
I was like wow they're so exaggerated
like come on that's right I think I
wouldn't think try that I would think
like you'll get side I shook off with a
Japan if you just call for sneeze people
like look at you like what the really
you're going to the dab it my shirts
I've seen you do that it's odd
you're supposed to I'm doing it for you
I just found it on I'm doing it so I
don't spread my [ __ ] I just judged the
way that you did it man I want to be
your friend that's all I'm just doing a
little too weird to be my friend the
thing [ __ ] well I'm not your friend now
shoulda be shy just sneeze outside of my
sweater I've even if you start doing it
mostly I want you to sneeze in your
handshake is that yeah and shake it I'll
do it for you man
maybe a mini it went too far I think
this went too far
[Music]